guiden elle aimit pas où elle habitait
elle appelait l'appartement
l'appartement du
diable dès qu'il arrivait elle me
disaement je te laisse je te laisse je
raccroche il
[Musique]
arrive le soir du 22 septembre ou partir
elle avait dit à à Chloé de préparer ses
affaires et et elle était en train de
partir et il a pas
[Musique]
supporté
là elle pause elle aim bien prendre la
pause ah bah à chaque fois papa il la
prenait en photo elle prenait la pause
hein enfin quand elle s'en quand elle
s'en apercevait parce que ça c'était arg
à la maison de campagne ouais on faisait
sa
star comme d'ab c'était le jour tu te
souviens où a compé ses bonbons pour
savoir si n avait pas chipé
elle était trop forte pour ça alors que
on aurait peut-être fait mieux de nous
les compter oui oui parce que
bizarrement sa bte elle est toujours
pleine à
elle ça c'est c'est étrange mais c'est
vrai qu'elle était elle était
personnelle quand même hein ouais elle
était oui elle était personnelle mais
parce qu'elle a été levée comme ça on
l'a aussi c'est aussi nous qui c'est
aussi nous qui avons fait en sorte que
elle était un peu il devit comme une
petite princesse qu ouais surtout
surtout toi non pas surtout Mo si
fallait pas lui faire c fallait pas lui
faire ça fallait lui acheter ça c'est
quand j'étais petite parce qu' quand
j'étais plus grande elle était un peu
plus chiante ouais mais je pouvais plus
aller voir mes copines tranquille sans
me traîner mon boulet derni ah oui mais
elle elle voulait aller avec toi ben oui
je sais bien et j'étais obligé de
l'emmener
la faoto de
classe magnifique le chemisier un petit
coloron moi je suis l'aîné de d'une
fraterie de quatre enfants et Guilen
c'était la petite
dernière j'étais un peu sa petite maman
je m'en suis beaucoup occupée quand elle
était petite on était vraiment très
fusionnel on s'appelait tous les les
matins on quand on allait au travail
chacune c'était tellement fort en fait
qu'elle a même assisté à mon premier
accouchement elle a eu mon fils dans les
bras avant moi
ouais c'était une relation très forte on
avait
ensemble nous on est vraiment une
frattererie très soudée on lui faisait
toujours des petites farces on la
réveillait par exemple quand nous on
allait se coucher elle allait se coucher
beaucoup plus tôt que nous on lui disait
que ma mère elle elle l'appelait pour
aller à l'école et elle elle était toute
endormie elle redescendait de son lit
elle allait dans le salon voir ma mère
et moi j'étais je disais mais qu'est-ce
que tu fais là va au va faire dodo elle
disait mais faut aller à l'école
elle savait pas al elle les écoutait il
faisait il faisait les imbéciles avec
elle
elle avait beaucoup de qualité elle
était gentille elle était serviable
elle a des rêves de princesse hein
toujours comme les petites filles hein
enfin pas eu chance avec le prince
charmand parce
[Musique]
que Christophe et Guilen ils sont
rencontrés en discothèque ils se
sont fréquentés
pendant une bonne année avant de
s'installer ensemble et ensuite en 2010
ils ont eu la
petite quand elle a eu sa fille alors
c'était le nombril du monde elle l'avait
mis sous cloche sa fille cétait
[Musique]
incroyable il for vraiment un couple des
plus classiques il travaillai tous les
deux ils av un appartement il avaient
une petite fille vraiment un couple
classique sans histoire
[Musique]
lui c'est pareil il était très intégré
dans ma famille il venait on se voyait
très souvent pour les anniversaires pour
Noël on faisait des soirées on jou au
tarot moi je le sentais
froid lui il était un peu froid un peu
distant mais moi je mettais ça aussi sur
le fait que nous on est tellement proche
que c'est compliqué pour rentrer dans
notre bulle je l'aimais bien il était
gentil
mais je disais à ma fille je je sais pas
il est il me glace il me glace le sang
quand je le voyais il était toujours
sérieux il avait du mal à rire et
ouais il me
glaçait
je suis Aziz j'ai 20 ans depuis petit
j'habite au PL surobinon le quartier
s'appelle le pierrier et j'habite au au
59 je les voyais souvent quand il rentré
du travail ou Chloé de
l'école le père je le voyais souvent
aussi pareil dans la sur le parking il
avait souvent la
tête dans son capot avec en faisant de
la mécanique
et très aimable très gentil avec un
grand sourire à chaque fois toujours à
dire bonjour Gan je la voyais souvent
bon des fois ça c'est arrivé qu'elle
vienne nous dire de faire un peu moins
de bruit parce que je faisais souvent de
des soiré chez moi
elle était pleine de vie tout le temps
rigolée tout le temps joyeuse mais quand
elle était avec lui elle était plus
éteinte en
fait
j'ai déjà rencontré Christophe puisque
le soir il venait chercher Guilen des
fois avec Chloé des fois sans Chloé donc
chloé était quand même petite mais bon
il la laissait a priori seu ce qui
choquait beaucoup
Guilen j'ai rencontré Guilen car elle
est venu se présenter pour un poste dans
cette boulangerie et je l'ai prise en
tant que vendeuse voilà en février 2017
elle me parlait énormément de ses
problèmes personnels qu'elle pouvait
rencontrer donc au sein de son couple
[Musique]
elle me disait que le lundi quand elle
était en repos elle faisait le ménage
lui rentrait du travail et il lui disait
que le ménage était mal fait il
recommencé le ménage en lui montrant
comment bien faire le ménage voilà prise
sur elle ça c'est sûr ça c'est certain
mais c'est toujours pareil on s'en
rendait pas
compte des fois Guilen elle nous disait
oh j'en ai marre il fait ça comme ça et
tout alors nous on lui disait oui mais
tu sais Guilen tu es un petit
peu un petit peu chiante aussi hein je
dis alors elle dit non non mais elle me
dit maman elle dit tu tu sais
pas quand elle s'occupait de Chloé c'est
pas c'était toujours oui tu t'occupes
mal de Chloé les devoirs sont pas faits
comme il devrait être fait
[Musique]
elle a cassé sa grand aujourd'hui
je nous on s'en est même pas rendu
compte en fait que Guen elle allait pas
bien honnêtement
pendant j'ai j'ai rien vu pendant la
relation après je me suis dit oui elle
m'a elle m'a envoyé des signaux que j'ai
pas su
[Musique]
décrypter par exemple il choisissait la
quantité de nourriture qu'elle devait
manger ma sœur avait perdu beaucoup de
poids des derniers temps au lieu de lui
dire ah je suis fière de toi j'espère
que tu vas continuer sur ce chemin non
lui il lui a dit oui bah maintenant faut
que tu fasses attention à part prendre
le poids que tu as perdu cétait toujours
dans le négatif C jamais est fait comme
il
voulait il choisissait les personnes
qu'elle devait fréquenter et également
quand on j'avais au téléphone parfois le
soir ma sœur quand lui il était sorti
dès qu'il arrivait elle me disait
toutement je te laisse je te laisse je
raccroche il
arrive vous prenez une grenouille vous
la mettez audessus d'une casserole de
Bouillante elle va faire tout pour se
sauver et elle va pas se brûler par
contre vous prenez une grenouille vous
la mettez dans une casserole d'eau tiède
et petit à petit vous augmentez le feu
elle va mourir brûler et ben les femmes
victimes de violence c'est exactement la
même chose c'est petit à
petit ma sœur elle a jamais porté
plainte parce que je pense qu'elle était
pas consciente d'être sous
emprise j'ai remarqué des choses où je
me suis dit il y avait pas que ma sœur
qui était s enprise c'était vraiment la
cellule familiale ma peti elle s'est mis
en France pour des futilités une fois
elle s'est fait une tche de chocolat sur
le pyjama s'est mise à hurler alors que
moi mon fils il fait une tche de
chocolat il étale il attend que je m'en
rendre compte pour lui dire faut changer
le pyjama elle m'a raconté des punitions
aussi qu'elle avait quand elle faisait
des bêtises bêtises entre guillemets
parce que quand je lui ai demandé ce que
c'était les bêtises c'était courir après
les pigeons ou parce qu'elle avait fait
déborder trop d'eau de la baignoire je
dire quel enfant fait pas
[Musique]
ça
lui le weekend il était pas là souvent
il allait voir ses amis faire de la
mécanique ou que sais-je d'autre et elle
se sentait
seule je pense aussi que quand dans dans
dans d'un côté on a plus forcément la
tenenstion les Modou les gestes tendres
bah forcément on est plus enclin à à les
entendre d'un autre côté donc Guilen a
rencontré
ériic son amantin ils se sont connus au
sein de la boulangerie c'était un
client et bah Guilen je pense avait
besoin de ce contact physique parce que
comme elle était malheureuse avec
Christophe ben voilà elle elle a trouvé
un petit peu d'amour un petit peu de
bonheur avec cette
personne alors Christophe a été au
courant de cette liaison euh par
l'intermédiaire d'un corbeau charmantee
personne s'est cru bon euh d'être le
justicier et de dénoncer ma sœur donc
oui il était au
[Musique]
courant je les ai jamais vu se disputer
jamais jamais rien entendu aucun signe
qui me faisait peut-être penser que ça
allait mal entre eux ou même
rien on appelle Christophe parce qu'on
savait qu'il allait pas bien et on lui
dit voilà c'est tu es encore je ta vie
elle est pas finie des familles
recomposées maintenant il y en a plein
et et là il a une phrase où il nous dit
bah de toute façon je vais je vais
mettre le feu à l'appartement et comme
ça après pourra faire ce qu'elle veut
elle sera
tranquille Christophe il faisait
beaucoup de chantage au suicide
et et les femmes qui sont sous emprise
et les femmes enfin qui sont victimes de
violence aussi elles ont beaucoup
d'empathie et même si elles sont plus
àour amoureuse euh de de leur compagnons
elles veulent quand même pas qu'il meure
euh c'est aussi parfois le le père de
leurs enfants et tout ça donc c'est
compliqué quand il y a quelqu'un qui te
dit oui si tu me quittes je vais je vais
mourir
euh c'est c'est elle était dans une
situation compliquée elle savait plus où
elle en était à dire
[Musique]
vrai on est le 22 septembre 2017 et j'ai
16 ans
et à 16
ans j'étais à mis lieu de
mimaginer me retrouver dans cette
situation ce soir-là le soir du 22
septembre elle voulait partir elle avait
dit à à Chloé de préparer ses affaires
et et elle était en train de
partir
je suis Nathalie j'étais la voisine de
Guilen et ma
fille j'avais 12 ans le soir du 22
septembre 2017 je suis rentré des cours
et je suis partie dans ma chambre F mes
devoir et
[Musique]
ceterazrière du pour c'est pour
l'anecdote la finale de
colanta je suis dans la chambre je suis
allangé j'ai invité des amis chez chez
moi on devait être 7 ou
on a de la musique on discute on
rigole et on entend un bruit
sourd un peu comme une explosion ou un
souffle on a regarder par la fenêtre
mais on s'est pas plus inquiéter que ça
et là deux dames viennent taper à la
porte
elles nous disent ah bah je crois que ça
se bagarre ça crie j'arais pas à me
concentrer parce que j'entendais des
cris ça devient vraiment fort et je
demande à D d'aller voir pour demander
peut-être ce qui se passe ou juste de
parler un peu moins fort j'ouvre la
porte et je croise mon voisin du un de
mes voisins du rez-de-chaussée qui me
dit il y a le feu au
4e je monte je vais toquer une première
fois j'entends rien pas fumer rien du
tout je retoque une deuxième fois et en
fait c'est là que il y a la petite Chloé
Qui qui crie appelz les pompiers mon ami
Kilian il est venu et il on a commencé à
essayer de casser la porte c'est là que
j'ai vu des flammes dans le couloir
c'est là que je vois aussi la petite
Chloé donc kililian lui la récupère la
sort la descend j'arrive au niveau du 3è
étage et je vois kilian et Azis
redescendre
avec Chloé et Chloé qui dit papa a
essayé de suicider
[Musique]
maman bah la petite Chloé vient à la
maison donc elle c'est elle est un peu
bouleversée elle est choquée en fait
elle est en boucle elle dit tout le
temps papa a voulu suicider maman papa a
voulu suicider maman et elle sort pas de
cette phrase là à répétition donc moi je
comprends pas trop sur le coup mais je
me dis bon bah peut-être que là dit chez
elle il y a eu un truc qu'elle a pas vu
et ben du coup dès qu'elle est arrivé
dans la chambre j'ai essayé de la mettre
à l'aise parce que elle avait B elle
avait pas l'air très très bien et puis
elle disait qu'elle s'était brûlé le le
bout du pouce et que elle avait
[Musique]
mal par l'entrebaillement de la porte je
vois des flammes je vois énormément de
fumée dans le salon plus un incendie
dans la chambre de la petite et je vois
quelqu'un au sol dans le
salon
donc je décide de rentrer dans
l'appartement avec Kilian la chaleur
était horrible au point de vue chaleur
c'est comme si on mettait le four à 250
de qu'on laissait chauffer et que ben on
se met la tête près du four et quand le
four est chaud on ouvre d'un coup ça
donne une idée de ce qu'on a pu
ressentir kilian et donc le voisin
commenc à éteindre l'incendie
et c'est là qu'en fait il voit une nbre
passer et en courant dans le salon je
suis à 5
centimè du corps de Guilen euh je jouis
Guilen dans un état mais qui est qui est
indescriptible et là j'entends faut
jeter plus d'eau faut jeter plus d'eau
donc je me dis il y a une deuxième
personne et je comprends que c'est
Christophe mais je ne le vois pas
pourtant le salon est petit mais avec la
fumée je ne l'ai pas vu lui de T
l'événement
Chloé elle a continué de me parler quand
même de de ce qui s'était passé quand
dit que son père a jeté du feu sur sa
mère que c'est enin sa mère lui disait
d'arrêter et que lui il lui jetait du
feu
dessus c'est c'est c'est un peu dur à
entendre Chloé était paniquée puisquelle
entendait sa maman et elle me demandait
si elle allait si ça allait aller ouais
elle était plus inquiète pour sa mère
quand même elle parlait tout le temps de
sa maman parce qu'elle avait peur
qu'elle meure en fait c'était ça disait
oui c'est ça par que maman va
[Musique]
mourir de ce que je me souviens ils ont
sorti le père en premier et ensuite
c'est Guen qui est descendu après ça
elle était en fait portée par des
pompiers parce que le la peau était trop
chaude donc il pouvait pas la mettre sur
un rancard ou ou voilà donc c'était à la
vue de tout le monde et elle était
complètement brûlé
c'était c'est assez
c'est difficile à
enfin je men rappelle encore j'ai encore
les images mais c'est
c'était pas forcément facile à voir je
[Musique]
pense moi je je je passe après
directement au 23 septembre où euh le
matin je reçois un message
d'une personne que je ne connais pas
c'est le frère de Christophe donc là je
le
rappelle et il me dit que qu'il y a eu
un incendie dans l'appartement la veille
au soir et que ils sont tous les trois
hospitalisés dans trois hôpitaux
différents j'appelle la police
judiciaire et là on me dit venez
maintenant donc je prends ma maman en
passage on on se déplace mais on nous
dit rien on nous dit juste de venir on
me fait monter dans un bureau et là on
commence à me poser tout un tas de
question sur comment je m'entends avec
lui comment je m'entendais avec ma sœur
des différentes des différents membres
de la famille comment on s'entend
ensemble enfin et au bout peut-être de
15 20 minutes d'interrogatoire je je je
regarde la le capitaine de police et je
lui dis mais elle dormait ma sœur quand
il y a eu le feu et là elle me regarde
avec des gros irurons et elle me dit bah
non il a mis le feu sur
elle comme
ça là je me rappelle plus de rien parce
que j'ai l'impression que tous c sous
mes pieds mon esprit est sorti de mon
corps j'étais vraiment en état de choc
sidéré l' état de sidération et tout de
suite je pense à ma mère j'ai pas de mot
pour le définir parce que c'est
tellement fort que ça décrirait même pas
ce qu'il est pour moi il il m'a tout
pris c'est le dernier des salopards et
encore je suis gentille quand je dis
ça
quand on était convoqué par la PJ il y
avait déjà sa famille à ce moment-là au
vu des discours qu'on entend on comprend
qu'on vient pour la même chose et moi je
comprends que c'est moment ils sont pas
au courant
[Musique]
ouis
pardon du coup je me dis de quel droit
je peux leur dire ce qui s'est passé ou
ce qu'il en est il me pose des questions
et je réponds juste à question j'essaie
d'être le
plus simple
ouais sans sans trop leur donner de
détails ma mère était toute seule dans
une salle attente et elle a appris par
les voisins ce qu'avait subi sa fille la
[Musique]
veille on est parti à l'hôpital voir ma
peti voir Guilen moi j'ai uneinfirmière
qui m'a donné un un petit bocal avec une
de ses boucles d'oreilles qu' do enlever
c'est comme ça que j'ai su que c'était
ma sœur en fait avant de l'avir on a été
reçu par un médecin qui nous a expliqué
que il était même étonné qu'elle soit
encore en vie voilà qu'elle était brûlée
à 92 % qu' avait rien à faire pour
elle
pardon voilà que il fallait qu'on lui
dise en revoir et moi je lui ai dit de
partir mais je lui ai dit voilà faut
sert rien de te battre par en paix je
lui ai dit que je prendrai soin de de
Chloé et ensuite le dimanche matin à
10h30 l'hôpital nous a appelé pour nous
dire que c'était
[Musique]
fini nous étions situés ici pour pour
défendre monsieur jalajas monsieur
jalajas était dans le box entouré de de
deux
policiers
et la famille Bouchet était en partie
ici puis après dans le dans le
public j'appréhendais le tribunal parce
que je me disais on va le
voir mais en fait je le regardais pas je
crois que c'est ce qu'il y avait de
mieux à faire c'était pas le regarder
l'ignorer c'est la première fois que je
le voyais depuis
depuis 3 ans et je m'attendais en fait à
avoir
quelqu'un bah de marqué physiquement par
rapport à ce que j'ai vu de guiden et de
l'incendie qui a dans l'appartement j'ai
quand même eu un instant un blanc
pendant une demi-sonde où je me suis ah
oui c'est lui et il a rien en fait c'est
le premier truc que je me suis dit il a
rien il a quand même été brûlé à 70 % et
en fait je le revois comme avant le
drame
au moment du procès Christophe n'a pas
reconnu pour lui c'était vraiment un
accident il a voulu mettre fin ses jours
il a voulu s'imoler par le feu et Guilen
malheureusement et bien a a reçu des
éclaboussures et au moment où il simole
et bien tout l'appartement d'ailleurs
tout l'appartement prendra feu hein
parce que les sous-vêtements apparemment
de guyen étaient quand même un Bibé
d'essens c'était pas des éclaboussures
clrément c'était unbibé au moment où
Guilen a couru elle a elle est tombée
dans lesessens elle a glissé dans
l'essens et raison pour laquelle à mon
sens on a retrouvé ses vêtements imbibés
d'essence ça c'était V ligne de défense
c'était ma ligne de défense mais c'était
celle de de Christophe et je le crois
quand il dit
ça je veux que la Cour le juré lui dise
mais mon petit gars ce que tu racontes
c'est pas vrai et tu es coupable tu tu
l'as
tué les conclusions des experts
incendies ont démontré que le corps de
Guilen boucher avait été l'objet d'un
déversement abondant
[Musique]
d'hydrocarbures
Chloé ce soir là comme il y a il y a eu
le feu dans l'appartement et qui était
vraiment très intense in allit des
fumé elle a failli elle a failli passer
aussi Chloé ce soir-là donc oui oui donc
ils l'ont mis sous oxygène à l'hôpital
et ensuite comme moi je me suis tout de
suite positionné pour la la
recueillir la l'aide sociale à l'enfance
a demandé à l'hôpital de La garder à
l'hôpital le temps que je passe devant
le juge des enfants qui me l'a confie
pour éviter qu'elle passe par une
famille
[Musique]
d'accueil euh je disais mot pour mot
c'est quand qu'on m'adopte tout le
[Musique]
temps je voulais que Tata m'adopte parce
que bah je veux porter que le nom de
famille de ma mère pourquoi parce que
euh bah mon père c'est une grosse bêtise
qu'il a fait bah j'accepte pas vraiment
sur l'adoption dans ma tête ça va faire
qu'au moins ça peut remplacer un minimum
ce qui s'est passéin la perte mais ça
c'est qu'une impression je te l'ai
expliqué que dans mon cœur ça va rien
changer qui l'adoption ou pas l'adoption
ça change rienprès c'est pour toi que ça
va changer de te refaire une
famille on a fait la demande le tribunal
il a dit quoi oui il a dit oui qu'il
était favorable à l'adoption et manque
plus que retourner voir un autre juge et
après c'est fait oui mais surtout moi je
me demande quand ça va se faire bah la
justice ça prend toujours un petit peu
de temps mais c'est mais tu avais dit
bientôt il y a 3 mois il a 4 mois je
sais c'est mais c'est la justice c'est
un peu long c'est voilà c'est c'est
c'est en bonne voie en tout cas ils nous
ont dit oui donc il y a plus qu'à
attendre un petit peu et et ça va se
faire ou et après on fera une grosse
fête et même un jour où je m'étais
trompé je t'avais appelé maman ouais
mais qu'est-ce que je t'ai expliqué bah
que tu pouvais jamais la remplacer
vraiment et que que je je la remplacerai
dans tous les actes dans lesquels tu
auras besoin de moi mais dans ton cœur
je peux pas la remplacer parce queune
maman n en a qu'une seule mais voilà je
ferait son rôle sans être maman voilà
parce que maman va pas
l'oublier voilà et je suis contente
qu'elle devienne ma fille
adoptive
mais je serais toujours là pour
[Musique]
toi